I'm talking from Basel I just left the
conference where we announced the huge
huge enormous partnership Silicon Valley
has met switzerland by doing a
partnership with the two giants from
Silicon Valley Google and Intel Google
and Intel will partner together in order
to make the next tag heuer connected
watch for the Swiss for us it's an
enormous contract it's an enormous
partnership because we are going with
the two giants to make an incredible
Swiss connected watch the swiss luxury
connected watch these jean claude what
do you think of the Apple iWatch are you
gonna wipe it out I think no come on
where we are not doing anything against
Apple we are we are trying to make watch
in our DNA with our characteristics with
our history with our emotions with our
design and the tide how your watch will
have to look like a tag or your watch
and you must immediately at first sight
recognize the tag oil output is a great
company is a great watch but we are not
at all fighting against Apple we are
trying to satisfy our customers who are
demanding for tag heuer to make a
connected watch a connected watch which
we could not do alone because in
Switzerland we don't they have the
technology attack level our like Intel
there is only one Intel there is only
one google and as those two are the best
we said for the hardware we need the
best people and the best people we
decided is Intel and for the software we
need the best people and we decided the
best people would be Google and that's
why we are connected with the best
people and if you have the best people
on board you know you are going to be
successful Nick John cloud where are you
in the process of developing this
competitor to the iWatch
you know Google and and an Intel have
been weeks in Switzerland working with
our engineers we have been several 10 20
times in Silicon Valley working together
in order to be able to present the first
watch by the end of the year and the end
of the year is in four months in 45
months we're going to show what is the
result of this enormous giant
partnership do you have a an example of
what you're trying to do here do you
make a prototype that you can share with
us on purpose we can share nothing with
you today because we didn't take any
prototypes we want we want the world and
we want our competition and we won our
customer to discover all at the same
time in october or november and to say
wow at the same moment in october or
november which means we are working on
the surprise we don't show anything the
only thing people know now is who are
those two partners and imagine if you
have such two partners you have you
cannot fail